foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
can you hear me
[Music]
[Music]
it was a pretty good game I mean we lost
more than we were supposed to
[Music]
we gotta you know train up some people
just some people want to get the helmet
and get crazy and start going
willy-nilly running into a pack of
people
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
what's going on guys so uh it looks a
little bit different I'm sure you guys
can tell it looks a little bit different
uh King don't even know what we're
looking at right now do you see it King
not yet sir the intro is popping you
know I love that intro
so that this is pretty much how I figure
we're gonna go
so what what I have learned how to do
is
do you
I see it now
I can actually
foreign
so pretty much what happens now
is we're able to I I can literally pull
the curtains back and forth
that's my dude
introducing
yeah I gotta get you in here because
sometimes
heavy like weird it don't work
there we go introducing black skin
[Music]
I am a creature of the night
introducing me
[Music]
well see the reason I did it this way is
it would be a little bit different this
time
it's a lot easier for me to maneuver
around these
if I have access to just
like shut the curtains you know what I'm
saying so I could I could do like what I
just did without them seeing it oh gross
because the curtains will be shut on
their end but not ours if that makes
sense makes sense
so what's going on man we we we've been
we've been missing an action for a
little bit man we had a little bit of a
break
well I want to say uh Happy uh New Year
because it's it's still that time that
we can say it without it being uh overly
used
uh so I went missing for like a date
right like I got off of social media
and uh my boy was going crazy my boy
attic was going crazy
um tell me how was those minutes sir
yeah I was generally concerned like
here's the thing like you don't go
missing from everything so I was like
okay he hasn't been on Facebook he
hasn't been on Twitter
he hasn't been tweeting to PlayStation
Fanboys he hasn't read anything in the
IOP chat like
I was like I even put in the IOP chat I
was like has anyone heard from King
clicks you know and I love that you know
a lot of times people take for granted
that if they aren't around or you know
um nobody looks for them and I really
appreciated that I just you know it's
very rarely do I get uh at least three
days off from work right very rarely do
I get like at least a chance to take at
least 10 hours sleep and the weekend
prior of you know for the you know the
solstice week and how the Christmas
weekend uh I had my son
so I had the four day weekend but
got to spend time with my son so you're
not gonna get that much sleep so this
weekend even though it was New Year's
weekend uh we still got our sleep so you
know um me and the wife hung out and you
know we got our sleep and you know we
turned off our social medias and stuff
like that so it is really it made me
feel really good that if I do something
happens somebody's gonna come looking
for me type of thing you know
yeah
um someone in the chat did have a
question uh normally we wouldn't answer
gaming questions but I do know what's
wrong with this one so I'm gonna answer
it for you Aaron J uh Johnson you say I
have a right so I bought game pass but
just got the Xbox series X and Game Pass
not working so do I gotta have two Xbox
game passes no you can game share
between your old Xbox and your new Xbox
and have access to both game passes but
you have to make uh you have to make
home on the other Xbox yeah so pretty
much like when you're on that Xbox it'll
go off the licensing on your account and
when you're on your actual Xbox or the
other Xbox it'll go off the licensing of
your actual account not the actual
console
what's up Peking what's up my you know I
guess fortnite dude I guess we'll get to
uh the homework uh first off I I want to
point out that King hit me up randomly
last time yes sir and he was like watch
this called the invitation
and I was like I guess
so I I watched the invitation it's about
like a like a vampire kind of thing
going on and um you know I want you to
lay it out since you're the one that uh
gave me homework the day before it
happened all right so check it out um
the wife and I we I'm always looking at
Netflix to see what movies are coming up
next and I was anticipating you know the
invitation because the trailers look so
good the trail is I mean the trailers
really sold it to me so I love Anne Rice
movies I love Bram Stoker's Dracula I
love Dracula uh 2020.
um and the Netflix uh series Dracula I
like that
so I'm like okay good we need a new
vampire film and this should be it
because it was alluding to a vampire
film it wasn't sand so much and I was
like yo I am so anticipating it so when
it was there we was like yo we're gonna
watch it this weekend so after I
finished watching it and I realized you
know we really didn't tell what we was
going to talk about uh were movie-wise
for the first uh show of 2023 and I was
like yo addict how about it be cool you
know we watched this so I sent that out
to you I was like hopefully he has the
time to watch it and I'm so happy that
you did watch it because I really want
to pick your brain on this film this oh
boy
I actually liked it um the only the only
thing I didn't like is
I felt like they had an opportunity to
do something at the end that you weren't
normally see in some vampire films I
guess we'll just go ahead and go into a
spoiler alert real quick
or not because spoiler alert's not
working because our
I set up spoiler alert King but I didn't
I didn't put the cameras in spoiler
alert
all right so I'm not the normal one yeah
I'm not I'm just gonna do this for this
part right here we're not going to be on
this long uh
I I did it and what here's here's what I
want to say okay on here you know I'm
gonna go ahead and spoil this because I
feel like this is a very important
aspect of here uh most of the time you
have like some motive alternative motive
stuff is the reason like
vampires like get to to the point where
they can fight someone like Dracula
because it to me the dude that was in
there he was low-key Dracula
yeah he just couldn't say it yeah so
what my question was and I think they
actually did a really good job is they
showed like another way that they can
get Dracula out of there yeah and how
they pretty much did it is they're like
look like we're going to go ahead and
the only way to like
it's kind of weird how they did it they
had it to where it's like
Dracula has three wives like it has to
have some form of like a ritual to to
for him to be Almighty and all-powerful
yeah and what I liked about it is I kind
of I kind of expected it because it felt
like they were going that way
but what was interesting is how they
ended up doing it like they was like
what we're gonna do is we're gonna you
know you're going to drink his blood and
he's gonna get you you're gonna get his
strength and then we're gonna drink and
then he's gonna drink your blood which
is going to initialize our bond and
we're gonna be able to
to live forever yep what I liked is she
was okay
yeah after she learned she was nothing
she could do she oh so I'm gonna get his
strength if I drink his blood I just I
felt like what happened when that
happened
could have been a better outcome like
because I'm thinking you know they're
gonna rule that she she was just gonna
just like yeah and especially like there
was this point in that one that that was
going on
she was drinking way more of his blood
than you could tell the other ones did
yeah so I'm thinking she's doing that
intentionally to weaken him you know
what I'm saying but
to me you didn't need to weaken him
because you were clearly so much
stronger than him like I that's that's
the biggest
criticism I could give is I felt like
that particular point they should a
little bit more back and forth between
them well this is this is all right so
I thought from the trailers it was going
to be at least a B plus type of movie
right you know and
Emily Emily is the um protagonist in in
the film
and she's broke she has no family and
she lives in America
so you know those those uh those find
your family uh ancestor.com yeah
ancestry.com type of things well she was
doing a catering event for that place
and they held like the secret thing and
one of her friends gave a gift bag with
it
one of the ancestry uh.com type of
things don't y'all ban us for saying
that um was inside the the package and
her curiosity got the most of her and
she filled it up now remember she's
broke she barely uh getting by she
doesn't have any family and she doesn't
have a boyfriend all right and her
friend you know makes it known that she
hasn't been with a man in a while and a
dating scene in New York sucks terribly
so she gets a hit back and the hit back
is this Rich cousin that lives overseas
the rich cousin that lives overseas was
like yo we wouldn't we should meet we
should have lunch and he meets at this
Posh hotel and then he'll he's like yo
tell me all about yourself tell me
everything tell me about your marriage
that is tell me about everything real
quick real quick yeah tell me I wasn't
the only one the whole time this man's
talking I'm like something's up with
this dude something is up with this dude
you
Rich cousin from across the seas
we we all were sitting there like he's
white and she's black and she's black
you know but then he tells about the
Scandal
family I felt like
obviously that's believable but I felt
like that was awfully convenient you
know what I was saying it was but she
was family though see that's the best
part about the whole thing it wasn't BS
it was just like really you know what it
is so long story short she gets to the
castle and the dude that they introduced
it to but this whole time she's been
thinking that she's going to a a wedding
right so she meets this dude and he's
the owner of the castle Carfax Castle
handsome young man I think actually he
should play Wolverine I think he should
play the new Wolverine I think he's
young enough I think he's uh the perfect
height I think he has a perfect
temperament to play Wolverine he's my
cast for Wolverine I got to get his name
anyway
um so he tries to woo her he has all
this money and stuff like that
and it just wasn't easy
no she she absolutely wasn't you know
she she had New York mentality
and you know they they try to
indoctrinate her into the fold now
there's a lot of layers and there's a
lot of missing plot points there's a lot
of stuff that was talked about and I
just felt the movie
wasn't cohesive enough or wasn't smart
enough to follow up on certain things
right like uh some of the stuff that was
going on in the basement some of the
stuff that was going on in the library
some of the stuff that was going on in
the cellar it was it was different
things happening all over the place and
they had different maids and different
stuff and it it just had too many plot
holes for me and then the ending the
ending purely threw it in the bushes
yeah it kind of felt like they were
trying to build up to maybe a sequel I
don't know yeah but I I felt I felt like
it did enough to entertain me yeah but
it didn't do enough to make me
consider it like a good vampire movie no
um I still am a firm believer that the
underworlds is the Kings when it comes
to the vampire stuff because I felt like
they did a good job merging everything
together
obviously I you know I asked about
wolves and
is a plot hole there too
yeah so it
what would you give I'm kind of curious
what YouTube
popcorn I will give it two popcorn
because it the the the plot holes it is
suffering from early Netflix itis early
Netflix films was this template
plot holes not finished product wasn't
really all that good and then I get to
see the Excellence inside Netflix you
know where like um what was it uh or the
one with Jamie Foxx and Snoop Dogg was
it uh um that was
man what he he was hunting vampires in
that he was hunting vampires too and
that was a really good thing and what's
his name just showed up out of nowhere
Snoop Dogg like out of nowhere vampire
he was a hunter though you know Netflix
I know it'd be one of the first things
I'll pop up oh shift shift yeah day
shift right shift yeah so you know that
film was good and and that form was what
Netflix is now
right so I just felt that this was a
throwback to early Netflix when it was
trying to scratch and Claw away so I
look at as an indie film so I give it
two popcorn bro two
um
I'm gonna give it three
uh because I I do feel like it
entertained me to a point
um but I was very disappointed like I
said at the end because I'm thinking she
about to be him in his own game you know
what I'm saying it it didn't really go
out that way I didn't live up to you
because I kind of felt like it was just
because that would have been the first
time I've ever seen someone try to be
Dracula like that in that particular way
yo I okay when I saw the big tall girl
with the big situations
I said I got to get rid of my evil uh
Village I said I gotta buy it because
that woman looks like the girl from
Resident Evil Village to me and
I said man if they do what I think
they're gonna do with this girl at the
end where she can usurp this guy and
take his power for herself and make it
like she's she's the master and he's the
you know the subordinate I'm down with
this
another thing that kind of like
they kind of were building up that one
of the Mistresses wasn't enjoying what
was going on but I felt like they didn't
do a good enough job and when she did it
kind of didn't make sense like because
you could tell that she she was
conflicted on what was going on but I
never thought she would betray the other
chick you know what I'm saying are you
talking about the young ones
yeah yeah I felt like they could have
built that up a little bit more you know
because it kind of felt like she just
betrayed her for no reason like well she
really liked the spunk of the other one
and she gave her hope because remember
the other one was just too dominating on
top of her and she gave the you know
Emily the the protagonist told her yo
it'll be dope if you come to New York
and she's like I would love to go see
New York like I saw New York in films
and I would love to and the funny part
is just like
there it
she ends up being
like the stab in the back thing and I'm
just like
I felt like you see I like the concept
when vampires
the longer they live the stronger they
are you know what I'm saying that was
not the case here no this one was that
the big one was 500 years old and the
smaller one was a hundred years old and
Emily was just not even a day old yeah
and somehow she fought Dracula in one
like oh when she chopped his arm yeah
that's the part that that just what I
did like is she used the wiring on her
dress to cut his arm so that was a
little unique but you know I'll go ahead
and go back to the non-spoiler room uh
as far as that it's just you know they
they they could have improved that I do
hope they get a sequel because I feel
like there's something there
it's just I didn't like how they left
off though because like it was dope the
four families
um coming together
forming this this this this Cube that
the whole town would benefit from you
know I think I thought the whole town
will be forever young that old lady was
like yo don't you F this up like when
she busts upside the head yeah it seemed
like it was only the vampires that was
getting the the for everything it is
what it is so all right
I watched Bucky you watch some more
Attack on Titan who who Who's going
first all right let me go first with
this Attack on Titan right so I thought
I thought honestly I would see the other
episode
so check it out I'm watching an episode
of Attack of Titan and I think attic is
completely on to something right because
um again I was bored all the way through
and I'm like I told my wife I said yo
let's put on this thing so I can fall
asleep so we put him on Attack on Titan
yo so the big the big red Titan comes up
with the one with the missing all the
skin right the big one he shows up so
Aaron Aaron is like oh God this is the
day that I'm putting you down and Aaron
is putting in work yo because they break
the front door Aaron is not trying to
inherit so Aaron goes around the back
and he uses those those the um yeah the
only gear and you know they hook on like
a little Spider-Man thing and they
swinging around and he has these two
blades yo so they know the back of the
neck is the weak spot I want to know who
the hell found out the back of the neck
is the weak spot but anyway that's I
digress so he goes to go slash it he has
to open it and I'm like yeah he bout to
take old boy there dude disappeared B
like he disappeared he wasn't even there
so he's like yo as easily as they appear
they can disappear which is really
messed up so everybody's rallying trying
to get up and and uh you know because
there's still the little Titans is still
coming through the door and they don't
care climbing through so everybody the
squad got to get up and they got to go
get them some dudes just panicking some
dudes just throwing up some dude just
you know crying and moaning about oh
tomorrow I was supposed to be in the
interior I wouldn't have seen any of
this and you know Aaron is like yo suck
it up B get up in there you gotta handle
your business because we all Warriors he
gave him the whole Spartan treatment
these dudes was jazzed up leathered up
ready to go and they walked out the room
and you I swear it was a it was like um
like that like that that that the
astronaut when the meteor was about to
hit the earth and those dudes was just
walking on the astronauts look dope it
looked like that right so they coming
out you think they about to go out there
and do some work like they got their
motivation I swear to God
I said they gonna take down some Titans
on everything I love they got decimated
real quick real quick it wasn't even
fair because they swinging into action
and you see all these action poses and
they pulling and they slide and they're
getting all into it pause
One Titan jumps out of nowhere
and then he's holding the building
so everybody stops they call that
abnormal Titan one that doesn't act like
the rest of them well he did enjoy
didn't yeah and he peeked around and he
had his mans in his mouth pulse and you
know he's like
yes that's when it went downhill
straight from there
I got a chance to see
the dude the Spartan leader the dude the
young dude that struggled so hard to
learn how to fly in those those little
rigs
the inspiration I got a chance to see
the inspiration get swallowed I said I
can't believe what I'm watching so I got
to see the next episode you thought he
was the main character didn't you bro
he saved this boy like he went inside
the Titan's mouth and got his boy out
the the main character Is Mikasa it's
not him
they have me food they had me food all
the way through I am not gonna lie I was
really attached to this kid I was
looking at his journey because they they
fooled you they set you up from the
beginning because you're looking at his
mom's get eaten and this kid is like if
when I grew up if I'm gonna kill Titans
if you remember correctly when she seen
when he's seen his mom's getting eaten
Mika says there in that exact scene too
what it
it's the biggest bait and switch
in a cartoon
an anime that I've said could you
imagine if you're watching seven deadly
sins and and and they killed the the
captain and meliodas in the beginning
you know they had made a new movie
there's a new movie yeah I gotta I gotta
watch it it's tracking I'm I'm a sucker
for them though
it works horrible like oh because they
probably give it to another Studio yeah
well give it back
but that's what happens with Netflix and
stuff like that you know they get too
high on their own Supply and then they
just Farm stuff out and it doesn't go
well but I'm not gonna lie you were
right 100 percent
it did pick up and I am anticipating
watching it so you're right you ain't
seen nothing like oh God what you're
saying is is light light like they're
they're expecting an enemy problems
eventually there'll be like variety a
variety of different forms of Titans
that they have to fight and yeah it's
it's crazy because how they do it is
every there's three walls and every time
they lose a wall they force the
population back yeah and there's just
not enough
Farm space in the inner walls to supply
everyone
so what we're going to see because I saw
um the dude being pissed off uh what was
it Marquis Bart you know he was pissed
off because he was playing cap uh
playing chess with the captain and he
thought the captain he was really being
real disrespectful and anybody with any
ounce of a brain cell knew that the
captain was throwing it you know just to
uh you know pass the time with the dude
but when he took his alcohol he was like
yeah I'm gonna drink this because I'm
going to go and uh help my guys win
it was like really you can't even drink
this because I'm gonna die I'm dying
about 10 minutes
it was crazy I'm I'm not gonna lie I did
not expect that to happen I thought it
was going to go down there at least take
out two Titans they took out zero see
the best
Titan killers in that show is the Scout
renjamin and they're not there so that's
why you're not seeing like a lot of like
Titan killing like no we're gonna see
this one the majority of the people that
can actually handle themselves they're
not even in the walls
and one would think that you would leave
some of them there to protect them like
well you know I think about three
episodes maybe four you'll come across
one of my favorite characters his name's
Levi that's all I'm gonna tell you his
name's Levi okay so I'll I'll see um I
was real so let's get to this Baki
though
all right hold on hold on
we got the angry therapist MD five
dollars thank you for this illustrious
five dollars in a brand new 2023 year
the first guy is Super Chat on r r with
the lodge Attack on Titan is almost as
depressing as berserk
[Laughter]
all right I don't know I didn't finish
it off yet
so
I like it
you ain't like it I didn't like Foxy no
I I I try to watch it I think that
they're trying to capitalize too much
on the gore than anything like he'll be
sitting there getting hit
and they'll be sitting there like make
it like you telling you all this lore
and stuff but no explanation of why they
can do this [ __ ] they do
oh because his pops is they're like he
can't fight it in the world no I'm
talking about the other people that's
fighting with him they'll be like oh you
know he did this and he's did this and
the reason he could do this is because
of this and and then it's like they're
not explaining why any of them could do
the [ __ ] they do and like I don't care
if it's on that that power though I
don't care what your family is I don't
care like like I don't care you who
killed your clan members I don't care
who you kill clan members I don't care
about no tattoo on your back explain why
you can take shots to the face
yeah that's that's the word that's like
the Tekken world see I come from like
like you know Street Fighter cartoons
and Tech and cartoons this is the
ultimate iteration of that that and and
the kensei tournament the kensei
tournament is dope to me too I'm giving
it a one one popcorn you do you hear
these people
a one
I'd give it a zero if I had a zero
yet we're talking about the goat but I
got to episode like seven or eight and
it's just like crazy after I saw the
dude get the grenade put in his mouth
and I was I was done like it's like
clearly they don't even take their own
self serious like the dude literally
there's no skin on this on his mouth but
somehow he continues to fight and I'm
just like nah I'm good I'm good well
he's these are super humanly trained
they don't explain why they're
superhumanly strange did you see how the
dude climbed out of the um out of the
tube like they had them under an
underwater base and did you see how he
climbed out where it was like it was
smooth as hell but the sheer grip of his
fingers his only his finger you're
talking about what he grabbed when he
grabbed his his hands like because he
was like he because what's funny is like
this dude was grabbed before and I guess
it didn't matter then but when they
needed his grip to matter then it
mattered like he was Grand at the
beginning when he was against the tree
it didn't seem like he could get out of
it then but man like two episodes later
he's like did I mention how his grip is
and I'm like oh no you did it it's like
I'm pretty sure he could use that grip
two episodes ago
when they put them in the hospital
and then you come out there and they
make you think that fight's over and
they're like let me tell you what
happened nice
yo I like when they had to do in the
precinct and the cops thought they had
them locked up and the the chief is
taking a piss and then he looks over and
the guy's taking a picture
he just gets up and breaks his chains
I just came here to tell you guys so
uh it was I love it I love I love Baki I
love bakihama I love kenson tournament
you know what the best thing about Baki
was though
man you crazy see
I I can't go with you on that I can't go
with you on that
see
Jaren said Junior says bachi's sick
yes sick in the head
the little green men returning what
little green man returning what the hell
you talking about
I'm looking at Johnny Smith Johnny
elaborate let's let's let's move on
let's stop okay let's go
uh so you know I'll let you use the uh
Take the Lead when we talk about this
Marvel stuff so apparently Robert Downey
Jr he might potentially throw him or he
might be coming back uh to play Iron Man
so uh what what's going on with this
what's the contest are DJ is back in the
building baby
I cannot wait to see how they bring him
back he's probably gonna be superior
Iron Man or uh AI version because
remember Iron Heart
Tony Stark is supposed to be her Mentor
right so in the books he's supposed to
be her Mentor how they brought her in is
that she's done all this stuff on her
own but she's made her own Iron Man suit
and she's looked at uh how the Arc
Reactor is and she's built her own stuff
it would be really good for her to get
uh old
um probably uh uh AI hard drive of uh
his uh thought impressions
like kind of like how he had um I forgot
the name of the one he used I think it
was Iris uh that he used in Iron Man I
think it was three uh or when he fought
the Hulk with the Hulkbuster and I think
it was Iris that he used so and
technically he can have his thought
process his thought patterns uh put into
a AI uh interface right it can also
produce Holograms where he can actually
talk his remember with Mysterio Mysterio
made the tech Tony brought the company
and took the tech from him that's why he
was upset that's why Mysterio was upset
with Spider-Man and Tony Stark because
uh the link to Spider-Man was uh Tony
Stark and he went revenge on that
because of what Tony Stark did to him
and made him look like an idiot that's
AI
I mean that same holographic Tech could
be used to bring Tony back to life with
artificial intelligence and those
cameras all around so I think that's the
way they're going to do it I think
they're going to go that way to help
bolster the Iron Heart character and
have him as a character in the um secret
Wars where they introduce Dr Doom and
other characters that way
but there's another theory the other
theory is through the king Wars there's
another uh um timeline where Tony
doesn't die and they pluck that Tony
from that timeline and bring them to the
current 616 timeline and Tony is alive
there which one sounds more uh plausible
to you and which one is better in your
opinion for the MCU
I think he's just gonna come back for
that movie I don't think he's gonna
that's the ongoing thing yeah I think
he's going to come back for Secret Wars
to be the Iron Man in that area right uh
and then after that's done he'll be I
think he's going to be an Iron Man in
another timeline
uh and they could get someone like I
remember like Tom Cruise was worried
that they're going to try to get him
he's old as hell yeah but um I think it
it makes more sense to bring back the
the Iron Man that we know and just say
it's a different uh variant and then
after Secret Wars just send his ass back
to his timeline so you don't have to
like because I don't think
I don't think Robert Downey Jr wants to
come back permanent like that but I
don't I wouldn't put it past him for his
fans and to celebrate Marvel him coming
back for a movie if it makes a good
movie right well he can bring the they
can get the whole band together because
you know you can get Steve Rogers back
as uh as a version of Captain America in
a different timeline you know um
I don't know it sounds plausible I wanna
I want them
with the secret was I really want them
to look at different timelines and
different versions of the characters
being used I really do I don't want them
to you know half-ass it right now
because they have the fox IP IPS and
they have all of their stuff Under One
Roof there's no reason now for them to
you know not give you exactly the full
story but they do have to introduce the
Fantastic Four and they do have to
introduce the X-Men in order to get that
stuff through five dollars from the
angry therapist he might be in armor
Wars
as an AI I think so
it's it's a chance that he's in armor
Wars building up to being in secret Wars
yeah uh and then I wouldn't be surprised
if after Secret Wars if homegirl gets
his AI like before he leaves like
they they make it before he like leaves
to like kind of Mentor her I don't know
um question with becomes a secret Wars
it is it like
hero or hero like Civil War or is it
like Heroes against villains Instagram
the first one
the first one
was the beyond the king and plucked a
bunch of Heroes and upon a bunch of
villains and took him to this place
called battle world and they were to
fight over fight each other until there
was a Victor to somebody can actually
win and they can get the wish of their
desire
Dr Doom winds up doing what Doctor Doom
does and steals the Beyond his power but
the Beyond his power is too much for him
and you know it reverts back uh along
with the
um what's this guy's name uh
the not the elemental man
um
his powers revert back they they wind up
going back the second one
is where Doom actually conquers him and
you know it's like Secret Wars 2 Doom
actually conquers him and actually uh
controls the power and he makes his own
Doom world where all the heroes are are
scattered all over the place the
molecule man and all the heroes are
scattered all over the place but they're
playing different roles so he really
mind wipes them and some dudes don't
understand why this reality happens some
dudes remember some people don't there
that was a better story for me even
though you know we have uh uh God Doom
up there at the top
um but uh because doc Doom is my
favorite as you can see in here
yeah well I'll get a kiss I can't see it
but um they could only literally see my
face in your face I can't see anything
around us so oh sorry guys I'll take
pictures
but in that in that in that one that's
the one where he grabs Daniel's body
throat and rips his spine out like uh
this guy uh uh scorpion so I I really
like how that storyline was and then you
would that's how you got Dr Strange
remember Dr Strange and um the the what
you call it of Madness and
that first one where he was chasing
Erica
um America Chavez and he told I need to
take your powers the reanimate it uh
doctor strange that doctor strange is
from Doom world he was Doom's right hand
man and that is the strongest version of
uh Doctor Strange which died so easy it
made no sense but that is he's the
actual one so the fact that we did see
that
kind of let you know that that world
does exist and that character did exist
so there's things that can happen with
that what how King works the good thing
about two is they're able to use the
different universes to their advantage
they're like look this is the strongest
doctor strange but it's a different
version of him that didn't get the power
that he was supposed to get you know
what I'm saying like yeah so they got a
little bit of wiggle room when it comes
to that I'm just I I'm intrigued uh you
know we do have uh some dominant movies
hopefully good movies we got um cars the
Galaxy coming out through Ant-Man coming
out here pretty soon we will be doing
spoiler cast on both of those movies and
the curious I I I know that
the the
criticism for phase four is valid I'm
not going to say it's not valid hugely
so but I do feel like there's a lot of
like motives that's being pushed in
those movies that hurt them but I you
know even if those motives wasn't there
I don't it's hard to come from Thanos
back to rebooting another Avenger set
you know what I'm saying like we were
gonna be disappointed with the a lot of
these movies regardless because we're
not coming from Infinity war to end game
and like it's just go it's it's
equivalent of going back to like the
original Iron Man the original Thor and
rebuilding the Legos to get to the next
Avengers you know what I'm saying but
the problem with that was phase four was
supposed to be doing that you're
supposed to have Miss Marvel you're
supposed to have iron heart
um all the Young Avengers uh you you had
uh the Scarlet Witch twins uh you know I
forgot what they're actually real
characters years yeah they're actually
real characters you know because she she
made them up and she her psychological
break is crazy the movie really didn't
delve too much into it but it did a good
job do you think they're gonna brain
Scarlett which back anytime soon
later on because she didn't die yeah I
talked uh when I was talking to Tyler he
felt like
she might come back for like big moments
but she thinks that character's pretty
much done for a while no
um uh Wiccan I think her son is wicking
and quick something Wicken is the one
that does the magic
um I forgot what his son's name anybody
knows let me know
um but these characters and then you
have uh a version of King the Conqueror
young that's inside
is there's a whole bunch of stuff that
they're able to tell they're able to
tell these stories they brought you
um a scar
you know son of Hulk inside the She-Hulk
series he could be part of the Young
Avengers uh so there's they they were
building up to it I thought people
agendas like you said got in a way of
phase four I thought phase four could
have been told better I thought
different stories would have been told
better James Gunn was supposed to be in
control of phase four but before they
decided to cancel them then bring him
back it was really too late because a
lot of things were set in stone and
people was moving forward with the
agendas yeah and plus you know
being like look at Robbie Downey Jr he
said he not Robert Downey Jr Johnny Depp
he says he refuses the work of Disney
anymore so yeah once those relationships
are severed unless there's an absurd
amount of money that's pretty much
saying I'm sorry money uh and a lot of
these big corporations they have big
egos they wouldn't do that so it is what
it is I hope that you know we we see you
know some pretty good solid storytelling
in these next couple movies I have a
feeling phase five is going to be way
better than that before way better way
better already
the building blocks for Ant-Man I think
Ant-Man is going to be the Age of Ultron
for the phase five and the reason why I
say that azer Ultron reason why I love
Age of Ultron Age of Ultron gave you so
many different characters that uh grieve
or break breathe life into the
storylines he had division Scarlet Witch
Quicksilver Ultron all these were done
there you know
um Bavarian Bond strucker these
characters Baron Zemo uh you know the
rise of Hydra we know now how how
serious Hydra was because of that the
Mandarin all these characters all this
stuff was done and we got a chance to
see it there so I believe that um Scott
Lang and you know Hank Pym and the rest
of the Ant-Man team is at the WASP are
going to show exactly the future going
forward because you know his daughter is
five five years later from the blip
she's going to probably take over as
Ant-Man like she does later well she
turns into like giant man but um
it's I think they're setting the stage
and I think that movie is the one that
sets the stage more so excuse me
than Guardians of the Galaxy I think
that movie is more of a pillar or a post
in a phase five I think Guardians of the
Galaxy I think Guardians of the Galaxy
is going to show some out of space stuff
but more so that is going to start
pushing King as you know as the bad for
going forward and King King is a good
big bad but not as bad as doom doom is a
little bit more cynical
yeah I think we're we're about to see
some
some crazy stuff going I I'm excited man
I'm excited we got the Mega Movie coming
out I think this Friday I'm not really
too hyped up on that uh you know
definitely
dip my toes in it did you notice that
Netflix has their ad support on now
that's their ads here now
I didn't know that yeah hold up let me
let me bring it up yeah it's there now
because like when you put
get started yes see plan for 6.99 it is
basic with ads it's 6.99 good quality
and resolution 720P
and watch on your TV a switch and you
can't download with the uh
the basic ads I would never here's the
thing
Michael I fell away when I pay for a
subscription service and I got to watch
ads
I did it yesterday with Crunchyroll
Crunchyroll shouldn't have ads oh man
let me tell you Nintendo was going
bananas in my Crunchyroll they were
going bananas all in my Crunchyroll and
when I'm watching Attack on Titan I
literally thought that it was going to
be
um less than
Dustin four ads probably
so literally they were not playing
around with these ads so I don't know
what what what button I hit but I
actually got a chance to
bear witness to Nintendo's new games
coming up
you know and um yeah yeah
wasn't too much of a fan of Nintendo's
pushing their games on to me at all but
you know if if that's what you can
afford
it's better to be in the game in some
form of capacity than to be out of the
game just because you don't like
um ads you know um I think being in this
economic time right now
everybody needs to have an ability to
have an entry in to uh being into the
whole Collective so yeah 6.99 is good I
mean I feel see I I'm
I don't like the ad thing but as long as
there is an option for me to pay a
little bit more to to take away from
that
I I do feel like having the 699 ads a
lot of people can go with that that's
the uh the most cost effective oh but
you heard what they're gonna cut right
what
password sharing yeah I heard about that
how are they gonna do that how they
realistically going to do that they're
going to see their whole subscriber base
fall to the ground Netflix is really on
a spiral down like oh man they gotta
make money I I get their their mindset
on that but I'm looking at these shows
in these movies and I'm like
Netflix I know that you're trying to hit
as many kind of genres as possible
but maybe you overdoing I mean let me
ask you a question let me ask you a
question being that we on the fact of
Netflix doing this pricing model and
this this this aggressive uh attack
against password sharing
do you think that this is a desperation
call for being purchased because
um not too long ago where there was
Smoke um I believe there's fire I know
you laughed at me y'all guys laughed at
me in the chat but um
do you think there is any thoughts of
Microsoft purchasing and I'm not talking
about Xbox
don't don't get it twisted I mean
Microsoft purchasing Netflix
I don't know if it's a good thing for
Microsoft I know it's a great thing for
Netflix if they're bleeding cash
yeah I mean
there's a little bit of truth behind
that I'm pretty sure they are here's the
thing Microsoft's got all this money
they don't want it just sitting around
and devaluing they got to spend it
um I do feel like if they wouldn't have
I'm kind of curious you know I don't
want to go too much down the rabbit hole
with Microsoft and I'm kind of curious
that they were Gore at putting that bid
in for Activision and blizzard because I
know that they want they were going they
were going to really attempt to buy
Discord but they really couldn't do too
much with that uh there's a handful of
Studios that I'm pretty sure they would
have got their hands in if they could
have Netflix they probably asked them
but they they don't want to seem like
they're going to spend right more money
right after they spend the money they
have now you'd hold up yeah
so I'm with you I'm with you I'm just
saying it was it's just a thought
watching the new pricing strategy and
aggressiveness of Netflix now the
question is do you think because they're
having this base entry because keep in
mind
a lot they're gonna make a lot of money
off these ads on this base too yeah
and
getting that money getting the 699
and having people pay more do you think
this might stop them from Raising prices
for a while
I believe so yeah okay I believe I
believe the um the stopping of raising
prices is once you stop the password
sharing then you force people to get
down and lay down right if you really
care about Netflix then you're going to
be in and then you give a small tier
pricing model for those people that was
disenfranchised right so you give a
small tail pricing model those people
get in that way and then the people that
were maintaining their own pricing
structure with the higher tiers will
continue to do so right theoretically
you can double the base
theoretically
I think
that
raising prices
stopping sharing
look I get it
that's going to help them but I think
you just got to have more appealing
content because I do feel like these
days
the reason they were flourishing so much
was it because
I share uh I I I'm I'm leeching off of
cognitos Netflix account you know what
I'm saying it was because Netflix really
had no competition in that Circle but
for years they'd had no competition
whatsoever now you got the boys popping
off Lord of the Rings pop it off you got
peacock getting exclusive stuff you got
HBO and stuff is good you guys put me on
that yeah you got HBO Max which you know
obviously we know what's going on with
that well they're dead you know this
year but yeah they were doing a lot of
good stuff you know
I think that's their issue now they have
to compete with TVs now I'm not saying
Netflix in my opinion is still the king
of the of this [ __ ] like yeah they still
have the better shows the better content
but
they got a lot of stuff no one cares
about
they got a lot of things that they try
to do and I don't know if that's
realistically worth the investment that
they put out to get to maintain those
people you know what I'm saying uh but
it's gonna be I think a lot of that not
to cut you I think a lot of it was all
that money that they spent out to get
those comedians do you remember when the
comedians like they spent I think was uh
50 million on Dave Chappelle
um they paid uh I think it was uh 11
million to a couple of other comedians
a piece and they had a big bid
for comedy
because I I think that was uh what was
pulling the crowds in and I think during
the pandemic that worked
that doesn't work so much now
yeah
I feel like their biggest thing is they
just
they need to
find good shows and and latch on to them
and and what's funny is I talked to
someone I can't get his name but he he's
in charge of like
leasing IPS and stuff to other companies
yeah and he told me addict you'd be
surprised how Cutthroat the TV in movie
industry is he says there'll be people
that will spend millions of dollars
buying ideals because they don't want to
compete with them
um they like someone to write a script
and they're like yo this this could be
the next Underworld
but the people who make underworld would
be like nah
um
yeah they're by the script and they
shove it that's why it's it's very it's
a very lucrative business if you're into
script writing if you're into script
writing and you're writing these scripts
and you and you you out there you know
pushing your scripts to Hollywood and if
you can produce these scripts on a
timely basis you know that's why you
know um uh 50 Cent you know uh does a
lot of his stuff with stars and he got a
lot of his scripts purchased he goes out
and purchase a lot of scripts from guys
and you know give him whatever fifty
thousand hundred thousand whatever for
the script and then take the script
million dollar idea yeah but you know
these ideas are are good ideas some
people don't have the ability to
facilitate these ideas or get these
ideas in front of people yeah it's not
even the ability like you need funding
you you uh a lot I'm sure a lot of these
scripts are altered to make sense to a
modern crowd too yeah and it's just it's
it's interesting that you know stuff
going on my Netflix
I'm sorry if they could continue with
this I'm just curious how they're gonna
how they're gonna restrict people from
password sharing like are they gonna do
I don't know what I mean even IP based
like people travel all the time the
people that travel just ain't gonna be
able to use their Netflix like I feel
like
they're going to do something really bad
and it's gonna cost them the market lead
it's gonna cost them the CEO because the
moment the dip hits
they're gonna fix it you already know
people backtrack every day
yeah it's it's funny man it's funny so
let's let's get on to the the last topic
man we about to head out here 2023 man
what what's what's some of your your
highlights when it comes to the movies
TV shows what was something you want to
watch
well um I definitely want to finish this
Attack on Titan stuff all right so you
know that stuff pushed to the side what
episode
I'm up on episode five I believe five or
six attack
um Titans season one I want
to see the Super Mario uh movie
I think I think it's gonna be really
good I'm more anticipating that movie
more than anything else to be honest
with you
um I don't know if we get the other
Avatar movie at the end of this year
because I think it's next year yeah you
know we could talk about that briefly
how they gonna copy avatar The Last
Airbender word for word bar for bar
what's that classic Beaver he says he
copied my he copied it word for word
Barbara what if the Breakfast Club or
something like that yeah like Drake that
that's just crazy man you know I saw a
tweet where the uh the the writer of the
avatar The Last Airbender and I love
that show that franchise is amazing I
can't wait for that and he's like he's
like you know when I originally made the
Avatar The Last Airbender I wanted to
call it Avatar but I couldn't because
James Cameron was doing something with
the word Avatar so I I went with avatar
The Last Airbender and he's like
how is it that the second one is called
way of the water if the third one is
called the fire Ash people imma be mad
we right be mad
be big man
James Cameron's in a different level
buddy someone said Avatar copy the
Avatar how did this happen
yo I can't wait for that I can't wait
for
um
Shazam
Aquaman 2 The Flash
every superhero film
I cannot wait for every show I cannot
wait for I waited for this stuff since a
child so to see this stuff on screen
it's it's it's it's it's mind-boggling
to me do you think that it's gonna hit
us less that you know that there's no
more Shazam with that certain character
after this or I don't know that I don't
I don't know if um uh Levi is is done we
don't know that we don't know if um he's
aligned himself with the proper people
James Gunn you know James I got a gun
what's what's funny is I'm looking at
this aspect and
I'm like because I watched Batman vs
Superman again and I saw Wonder Woman in
that I'm like man she was such a good
Wonder Woman and now it's gonna be hard
for me to see someone else playhurst
position you know what I'm saying
um
if they hold the the title of one woman
with Grace and dignity like Linda Carter
and I think uh Gal Gadot did the same
thing
I mean Linda Carter was icon right and
she held it for many many many years and
for a long time she was the only person
seen as Wonder Woman so when they were
going to Scripps and they were going to
uh uh takes they had the TV show one
that they was doing I thought that girl
looked very nice as Wonder Woman but
they wanted to go with the movie
and I think they'll have a if if they if
they can't get it back I think casting
to go well I think James Gunn will do
good at casting because it's very smart
for him to say we're not going to get
rid of Jason Momoa we don't like him as
Aquaman but he can definitely fit as our
Lobo that's very smart so I uh Levi uh
as Shazam I expect
probably they changed the tone of the
series
and and and and and have him still work
as Shazam or or something of that nature
something something can still happen
with it I don't think he pushed himself
out
um like I didn't think Jason Momoa
pushed himself out so that I think
that's why Jason Momoa was still around
uh there's a lot of characters that
could be used the flash definitely
pushed itself out so
you couldn't be more out than he is like
but yeah those are those are the movies
I'm looking forward to
um maybe a couple of ancillary movies uh
sprinkled in there uh could somebody
tell me did Creed 3 come out yet
uh in the movie theater I don't know
because I thought it was supposed to
come out in December yeah because I I
was watching Batman vs Superman again
and that moment where Wonder Woman
Batman and uh Superman like all get side
by side I'm like man like they had their
moments they just they didn't build up
man they didn't build it up like that is
where I think there should have been
more build up going in this Batman
versus Superman there should have been
another man of steel and they should
have been another Batman and then going
and then they had Batman versus Superman
yeah but it's just like man like
they they DC will find the perfect Olive
Loop and they just trip going in like
that see because all of that stuff was
based on the Zack Snyder
that was Zack Snyder's universe and WB
was hell-bent on destroying it and they
did just that
I mean Black Adam fits in that whole
dystopian world uh Dark Side uh he had a
whole thing literally littered it was
written it was ready and
they messed it up by bringing in Josh
Whedon to finish off the film
and they had to put out the Snyder cut
they really didn't have to it was a fan
service it was a money grab
but they told everybody was a one-off
and everybody
I thought it was fantastic yeah it was
worth the watch to me yeah I actually
felt like you know that could have been
way better than what we got that that's
when you know we was at Xbox Live party
and I said that that's where they messed
up after that
after what happened with the Justice
League
because you you should have felt an an
Avengers moment you know what I'm saying
yeah but she didn't
you had the shots you had like the like
the still pictures like when it was all
standing getting ready to to get on
Batman's air bat whatever that was you
know it's funny I I was looking at when
they killed doomsday that's why I called
you about doomsday and I'm like
why did Superman have to like deliver
the final blow well he could have threw
it to Wonder Woman
and Wonder Woman could have killed him
yeah without dying he would have been
like yo this thing hurts me here you go
let's kill him please
bad writing
um that they wanted to do the death of
Superman what are they doing The Death
of Superman it would have made more
sense if like Wonder Woman and Batman
both couldn't do it but it's just like
they both were easily able to do it you
know what I'm saying let me let me tell
you
if they would have did man is still too
and then went into the death of Superman
from there separate movies
right and and let it breathe let the
characters breathe let uh um well Ben
Affleck do his Batman movies let it
breathe
no
it was Batman vs Superman it wasn't even
his film
his best scene was when Alfred tell when
Alfred was a mercenary why is the butler
mercenary the the the biggest issue is
just they they got they don't want to
wait they don't want to build anything
they wanted immediate cash if if they
back in the day if they would have
started working towards a Flash movie
and a because Aquaman already had his
own movie they could have easily have
handled it but they they cared more
about getting the cells that an Avengers
would do than building the actual
Universe did you blame them though you
look across the street you see those
dudes catching checks
yeah but the thing that you you have a
better chance just waiting outside the
alleyway when they catch the check and
jump them and take their money like like
it's like they're going in there with
they keep going in there and and selling
Prime Jordans and then they they getting
the counterfeit Jordan's going in there
expecting the same money and it's just
like you don't have the same product
like something like Black Adam if they
would have built the universe correctly
more people would have watched it
because they're invested in the universe
may a lot of people wouldn't have known
the movie they would have went to know
the movie but now you have to pretty
much
Marvel sells all their movies off a
universe that you have to watch to
expand in the universe and DC feels like
it's segregated independent islands that
you have to go to that you hope one day
is gonna connect to a bigger city
and that's the problem you know Green
Lantern was supposed to hit
it didn't sadly
um
a lot of the films just what I told him
what I've been told is because Tyler
told me the Green Lantern is like a big
DC person and it's it's crazy that he's
not in these movies
he's he's but he was supposed to be in a
Justice League you know at the end where
the the Martian Manhunter shows up
that's supposed to be Green Lantern
oh they changed about the last minute
yeah because Martian he's in the Justice
League too right yeah but as a as a
small cut in the Schneider verse that
dude
because I told you like they could have
easily if they would have gave
the um the machine one his own movie and
they would have gave yeah cyborg flash
his own movie I think that's the the
extra character the thing with cyborg is
he talked about a lot of stuff in the
background about a lot of stuff alleged
stuff that was going on so he ostracized
himself from there like
be honest with you I think WB is too
sensitive because all the stuff that
shuri allegedly was doing inside the
Black Panther you didn't see her cut
they could have killed her literally in
the first couple of seconds of the film
the way they killed Angela Bass
but again they didn't and they left the
on to be the Black Panther so I think
they could have worked it out with with
the with with the actor uh as cyborg
they even uh made sure that they cast
another Cyborg on the TV show but what
movies are you anticipate I'm looking
forward to what you want to see in 2023
sir let me read this Super Chat hold on
you know you know what angry therapist I
really appreciate you today I really
appreciate everybody 75 people watching
uh the English MP MD
five dollars Super Chat thank you so
much Black Adam should have been uh uh
should have been after credit in Shazam
one
that's how that's what they want us you
know what they wanted was
Superman and Shazam
in a film
and them explaining that the chair the
empty chair about Black Adam because
remember there's a DC cartoon where
Black Adam versus Black Adam versus
Shazam and Superman Superman and Shazam
versus Black Adam and it's up on HBO Max
right now hold on we have member chats
General Mack member for 26 months what's
up all hail the IOP salute the Lord's
happy New Year Lords great to see you
guys looking forward to Xbox World Order
Xbox one
that's my dude Gerald Mack what's going
on all right fours and legs and remember
for 36 months not to be outdone by
Gerald Mack love you both Lord bronze
Lord Silva Sydney Snyder cut was the
best story well the Snyder cup was the
best story DC that they had Warner
Brothers made it their business to
destroy it is very sad you're not lying
that's 100 the truth and I'm with you on
that I honestly believe if he was going
to give it to cider you should have let
Snyder Rock hold hold on a second Forge
a legend remember for 36 months Lord
bronze uh Snyder cup is the best story
oh it was the same one
I'm excited uh when it comes to movies I
I want to see obviously the the stuff
that's going on I I really I don't think
Blade's coming out this year but I I do
want to see that it comes to anime I
really want to see the net uh the the
next Demon Slayer because that's going
to come out this year
and Attack on Titan's final Seasons
coming out this year so I'm just started
so I got mad yeah
I think I think movies movies to me I
only go to the movie theater now I'm
kind of like
I go to the movie theater to watch
the the the Marvel stuff and like
occasionally you'll get me to go watch
something else now because of this show
we'll probably try to make sure one at
least once a month we watch something in
the movie theater or something like that
it just depends on what's going on I do
think we should watch Scream
oh yeah yeah we're gonna watch that yeah
so little things uh most of the time
though it's it's gonna be you know
Amazon Prime exclusive stuff Netflix
exclusive stuff I know use having a
season two in February I I'm excited for
I'm gonna watch um some stuff off of
peacock some scary stuff
uh and I actually like the this uh show
which you know you could um this isn't
my pick but you and the misses I think
you guys would actually like watching a
Netflix show called Slasher slasher it's
pretty much like
like scream but I watch it this week
I'll watch slasher is it a series yes
so um how many episodes I think there's
three seasons but how it goes is like
you know the American Horror Story where
every season's a different vibe yeah
it's not it's like that every season's a
different killer okay uh so I think you
and her now that that's not my pick
that's just like a recommendation if you
guys want to play you you your homework
is Attack on Titan until you're done
with attack on all right I got you
um all right so listen guys
um before we get out of here
we're working on the patreon so what we
want to do is members and and members
both of them we're we're going to put up
a poll
and uh for the patreon for the members
to pick our movies to watch
all right for the week I think it's
gonna be like three of them there and we
can watch it that way I think what would
be a good thing to get we'll let the
members pick the movies and we'll pick
four of the ones that we want to try out
and then we'll let Twitter pick the like
poll from the movies like up okay that
sounds great yeah because we'll let the
members and the patreon members pick the
movies and we'll we'll get presidential
majority vote and obviously we might not
have majority stuff so then we'll pick
four of them and then we'll let everyone
pick which one we actually watch good so
then we can have a large mix of people
actually you know galvanizing and help
us craft this show and the reason I I I
I feel like that will be the best ways
because it was sure it will give people
a little bit of an audience of okay I
gotta watch it now because my my movie
won the poll you know what I'm saying
yeah so that's good and they have more I
just want I want more interaction and
more input you know I want I want the
the 70 people that's watching and and
the hundreds of people that's going to
watch it later to actually feel like
they're part of it you know because
that's what that's what I want you see
that empty movie theater I want it
filled with y'all
if it makes sense yeah and then you know
big
big stuff
you know we'll uh stuff that makes sense
we'll have uh uh guest appearances from
other Lords two dollar Super Chat from
Forza Legends DC anime is the best
honestly I actually think DC makes
better anime and TV shows than Marvel
well I think James Gunn needs to excuse
me look over to the TV anime guys and
get that done he really needs to start
elevating people
um and putting them into positions to
win because if that is your most
positive uh performing divisions
I don't understand the disconnect when
it comes to Translating that stuff to
film
yeah so so uh before I leave I want to
show you guys uh we didn't use it this
podcast because I'm still working out
the tweaks you'll see in a delay King
but see the middle guys I actually have
where it opens up you know we'll have
like Graphics back there if you guessed
it'll be there and then um I actually
have it closed too yeah I I have it
closed guys you know I I ain't playing
with this stuff man I have it closed so
it can open
and then when we're done with it when
we're done with it I have it to where it
will close
[Music]
your attic where do people gonna find
you this week brother talk to me you can
find me on Twitter at Lord addict ILP
um I was gonna post something today but
I I you know I got you know doing a
bunch of stuff so didn't really have the
time
I'm gonna I'm definitely gonna post a
video tomorrow about this Fable Fiasco
going on
um IOP this Sunday 1 p.m we're coming
back
um I I feel like
we have a lot to talk about
there has been a good amount of breaking
stuff not nothing like drastic drastic
but a lot of crumbs that can make up a
really nice well I mean I got some good
PlayStation stuff of course you guys
catch me uh Saturday uh at 10 p.m
Convent took with the King we have tank
Davis versus Garcia I'm my Dominican uh
brother my mono uh is going up against
the tank we can see if he can actually
pull it off with all the controversy
going on with tank is he focused in this
fight is this fight gonna be the fight
that he gonna take a loss is this fight
the fight that you bet and you win a
house we have no idea but I'm going to
bring this fight to you and it's going
to be sponsored by do say
um it's gonna be a fantastic fight I
know you guys gonna love it I'm gonna
love it so
um also I'm doing a large minute this uh
actually tomorrow but uh it would
probably post uh probably on Friday uh
and we're going to be talking about bad
batch the bad batch on Disney plus so um
if you want to know more about it before
watching the Lord's minute go check that
out but I'll be on Twitter getting a
hold of these dudes if they act up
trying to finish my DLC addict I'm
putting me to sleep bro put me to sleep
well I I do you on episode five of
Attack on Titan yes sir I think 10 11.
that's when it pops you know 10 11 is
where I want you to be by this time next
week okay I got you I mean I'm listening
I'm trying my best I'm trying my best 10
11. so I got you I got you
oh
and I will um what what do you want me
to watch I want you to watch the Ken
Singh tournament it's on it's on uh
Netflix what is that fighting just like
Bucky
[Laughter]
send me a message I got Facebook so I
know exactly what to look I got you I'll
send it to you I mean listen it's some
of the stuff is an acquired taste and
I'm really old school when it comes to
my anime so Ragnarok on Netflix I
watched a couple episodes of that that's
like a fighting tournament thing I
actually really like that it's got like
oh you're talking about the ones where
the gods was fighting yeah and Adam
versus Adam and Eve Adam came up and he
was fighting this hell yeah I love that
you like that one yeah I don't mind that
type like uu Hawker shows one of my
favorite animes okay and it's it's it's
got a lot of fighting mechanism and
obviously they got like powers and stuff
well I mean these these people in this
boxy show might as well have powers
all right but I appreciate it for coming
through this is Lord addict and King
David we'll see you next week
foreign
[Music]
[Music]